[Music]
official Washington spent two years
waiting for the model report remember
the anticipation but now that it's out
most people in DC have decided that
while they hate President Trump
passionately they don't actually hate
him enough to read 448 pages of texts
that's just too hard
so now true believers have produced a
cartoon version of the Moller report for
real CNN was very excited about this it
covers all of the major moments you've
got the dinner where President Trump
requested loyalty from then FBI director
James Comey there's an the Oval Office
screaming match where the president
demanded more protection from his then
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and yes
it does as well include his order to
fire
Robert Moeller may seem odd to do a book
review of a picture book but that's
exactly what we're gonna do tonight dan
bungee now joins us he's a former Secret
Service agent in New York City cop and a
frequent guest on this show have you
looked at these pictures Dan no because
I haven't taken neuroprotective
compounds I don't want to lose neurons
at about 20 IQ points by reading this
kind of imbecility but I'm just
wondering Tucker right I wonder if they
include the part also in the book where
where Trump tells us attorney Don McGann
to go testify for 30 plus hours or or if
they what if they include the Peter
stroke text right where he tells us busy
his girlfriend over text hey I don't
think there's any there there wait wait
here's another doozy they should have
included in the book when Peter strokes
girlfriend the FBI lawyer tells a
congressional committee as Muller's
appointed that this case could still be
literally nothing so we've been spying
on a presidential campaign you appoint
Bob Muller I wonder if that this could
be literally nothing is in the actual
comic book just checking with the
writers you know call me text me I'd
love to know I suspect it's not that's
like getting a big man yes you're right
yeah I think that's right so Muller is
coming before the Congress he'll be
asked questions what should he be asked
well the first question he has to be
asked is when exactly did you find out
that collusion was the biggest political
hoax in American history now Tucker my
research
for some of the material I was putting
together for a project I'm working on
indicates that it's probably no later at
best than July of 2017 remember he's
appointed in May of 2017 because that's
when the inspector general exposes
Muller's team to this infamous texts
about you know smelly Walmart people and
how Trump and all the subs are and so
mother must know there's something going
on there so we need to know when he
found out and what he was doing for 600
days after he found out he was
investigating the biggest hoax in
American history that's that's a solid
question I wonder if anyone will ask it
so we can't let you leave yet so
normally we meet on Fridays but tonight
we've got a special midweek auditioning
night of the Dan bhaji no news explosion
we got a feel instead of giving us his
top stories this week dan is something
special for us he's giving us the top
questions he wants more to face so that
is the first one we already got one give
us the next one you would ask the next
one is important this is a this is a
good one
someone needs to ask Bob Muller why it
is that he left out all of this
exculpate ory evidence in his report you
know I love one the left by the way I
did read the report multiple times
because I have to for my research
project I'm doing here but what's
fascinating is in the report he leaves
out all the information that indicates
that the Trump team is in fact innocent
I'll give you one easy example they talk
about these contacts these dreaded
contacts between Paul Madoff or this guy
Constantine columbic who has connections
to Russia and it's made to sound all
nefarious by the time you're done
reading you're like oh my gosh Paul
Madoff or it's like Agent X from the X
matter so this is incredi sold us out
until you find out later what's not in
Imola report that Constantine columbic
was a source for the Obama State
Department for a long time before that
and nobody brought up any of these
issues one more quick one
the attorney who shows up at Trump Tower
for that evil Trump Tower meeting where
they talked about Russian adoptions the
attorney who shows up was working for
the team hired by mrs. Clinton to gain
Oppo research on the Trump you're not
going to find that anywhere in the
Muller report which is really the Muller
op-ed that's what it is the Muller the
longest
I thought those Vladimir Putin's niece
or something but no Dan Bungie no with
the with the fax thank you Dan that is
an explosion to see yeah thanks good to
see you